your attitude towards failure can
literally change your life
so today i'm going to give you five
reasons that failure can be a good thing
and if you stick to the end you will get
my three tips on helping you to overcome
the fear of failure
reason number one why failure can be
great for you is it can help you
overcome your fears
when i had just started driving i
actually drove into
someone's house i mean the hood of the
car was literally inside the living room
and no i don't have pictures i was not
about to show the world
what i had just done but this experience
this
failure left me feeling like i was a
horrible driver it left me kind of
traumatized and from then on in my mind
i was
always a horrible driver when my husband
and i moved houses
he forced me to move a trailer with our
furniture inside it
me the person who had wrecked a house
i was certain that this was a wreck
waiting to happen
but to my surprise i actually did it
everything got home okay maybe a few
dents in it but nobody was hurt
all the furniture made it i did it when
my husband and i cleared land for a
house build
he taught me how to drive an excavator i
was horrified i thought i was going to
kill myself yes when i drove an
excavator i took twice as long and i
probably did it very wrong in the
beginning
yes when i drove a trailer i did some of
our furniture
but these failures helped me to conquer
the biggest fear that i was having that
fear
of being a horrible driver reason number
two that failure can be great is it can
help you become a better
problem solver what how can making
mistakes make you better at solving
problems
because failure forces you to come up
with new solutions and approaches to
problems that you're not able to solve
i love thomas edison's famous words i
have not
failed i've just found 10 000 ways that
don't work so if studying the same way
keeps resulting in failing grades
maybe you just need to study differently
maybe you need a tutor maybe you need a
study group
maybe you're not an auditory learner
you're a visual learner or vice versa
sometimes failure means that you need to
change direction
not stop and quit altogether we've
learned from darwin that those who adapt
to changes and struggles are those who
come out on top
so when you want to stop when you want
to quit when you feel frustrated
when it's hard don't stop adapt
try finding a new way in approaching the
problem
reason number three that failure can be
awesome is that failure can teach you
persistence
i love the analogy that tony robbins
uses to describe
failure when a child is learning how to
walk a parent just doesn't give him
x number of tries and if they fail
that's it that kid's not gonna walk
no they keep falling and keep falling
and keep trying again
until they learn to walk kids are just
naturally persistent
especially when they want something but
what happens as we
age why is it that we stop trying for
something
once we failed could it be that you've
let
others expectations of you weigh you
down
or could it even be your own
expectations
that you haven't lived up to that is
making you feel like a failure
reason number four is it can help you
become a resource
to other people who are going through
the same kinds of struggles and
hardships that you are
or have been and it kind of makes you
more relatable as well
this can be one of the most difficult
because to let someone see who you
really are
you have to let them see the ugly side
too your failures
but to do this it involves a sense of
vulnerability i find it very
inspirational how oprah winfrey
mentioned on an interview
that she noticed her audience become
dramatically more engaged and willing to
open up
once she first opened up about her own
life
and her struggles she went through major
struggles and had several failures but
she didn't let them stop her
and rather she actually used them to
help other people experiencing failure
which made her more valuable and more
relatable because she became a resource
to other people
your failures might suck but they might
just give you the knowledge and wisdom
to help you accomplish the things that
you thought were not possible
reason number five is it can help you
develop self-awareness
in order to improve at something we
first have to analyze what went wrong in
the first place
but how often do we face a problem and
our first instinct is
but it's not my fault when my toddler
grabbed a basket of eggs from the
kitchen table
broke them and smeared them all over the
floor i could have been upset by what
she did
but who put the eggs within her reach
when you have
a failure don't blame others your
situation or the economy
instead ask yourself what could i have
done differently
you don't have to live life seeing
yourself as a victim
yes you will have failures pains and
disappointments
but you are greater than your
circumstances
acknowledge your mistakes and own up to
them the ability to do this can help you
prevent
possible failures in the future and it
can help you to accomplish
greater things in my video seven lessons
i've learned from working with dying
patients
i mentioned that failure is not
something to fear but something to
pursue
this is because failure is where we
learn grow and adapt
successful people fail a lot but they
learn from it
so now that we've talked about why
failure can be a good thing
let's talk about how to overcome the
fear failure because for some people
just the fear alone is what stops them
from even trying in the first place
so tip number one hang with the wolves
my husband loves to say if you hang with
the wolves you'll learn how to howl
i love my father dearly but when i was a
child he taught me that a
woman could not do the things that men
could i would try to help him
by working on the yard or try to help
him fix things around the house and
actually learn from him
but he would remind me this isn't for
women go and help your mother in the
kitchen
so at a young age i kind of had it
ingrained in me that i would never
really amount to anything or accomplish
anything major in my life
but by the grace of god i made
relationships with true leaders
who actually pushed me to push myself
even further
and to try new things and not let the
fear of failure defeat me
so attract people in your life who are
positive who crave and hunger success
because these are the people that are
going to keep motivating you
to keep going keep pushing and keep
reaching your limit
and if you don't have anyone that meets
this criteria in your life
then read books listen to podcasts or
watch inspirational youtube videos
you are the average of the five people
you spend the most time with
so find the wolves and hang with them
tip number two learn to separate
yourself from your failures
this one was very difficult for me
because i always had the mentality that
if i
fail then i'm a failure so i was
incredibly prideful and i would actually
rarely acknowledge my mistakes because i
thought that doing so would make me weak
or would make me an actual failure
it's actually quite the contrary to be
able to admit that you have failed
and not feel like a failure requires a
degree of
self-acceptance and vulnerability
because one
you're acknowledging your mistakes and
number two you're allowing other people
to see them
allowing yourself to be vulnerable by
admitting to your mistakes can actually
be very freeing because you don't have
to try to be somebody that you're not
so ingrain in your brain i am not a
failure
i just failed or as thomas edison would
say
just learned one other way to not do it
again
and lastly tip number three push
yourself for yourself
not for other people when i was a kid in
school i won lots of awards and
certificates that never brought me joy
because i pushed myself
in the hopes that maybe if i worked hard
enough my parents would see them and be
proud of me
maybe if i accomplished enough they
would show me the love that i conquered
for
this was detrimental behavior because i
was trying to earn acceptance and earn
love and i was basically giving myself a
worth
based on how others perceived me not how
i perceived myself
but i remember my college graduation day
when my family was complaining and
frustrated because they had to drive
three hours
to get there i truthfully didn't care if
they attended or not because
this was about me this time i had done
it and i did not do it for them
there's a whole different feeling and
satisfaction that you get when you
accomplish things
and strive hard for the things that you
want to accomplish
not for what others are wanting you to
achieve or what others are expecting
from you
so those are my three tips to help you
conquer the fear of failure
if you have any more please leave them
in the comments and if you like this
video please give it a thumbs up and
subscribe so that you won't miss out on
my weekly videos
i thank you so much for watching and i
can't wait to see you in the next one